Znaczenie quantum computing jest jednocześnie niedoceniane
i mocno przesadzone.
Choć nie zastąpi klasycznych komputerów,
innowacja kwantowa reprezentuje nowy paradygmat obliczeniowy.
Komputery kwantowe mogą działać w symbiozie z obecną infrastrukturą
obliczeniową, żeby rozwiązywać złożone problemy, które wcześniej
uważano za niepraktyczne lub niemożliwe.
Może to zmieniać reguły gry.
Na przykład trudność rozkładu dużych liczb
na czynniki pierwsze stanowi podstawę współczesnej
kryptografii. Dla liczb stosowanych we współczesnym szyfrowaniu
z kluczem publicznym i prywatnym takie obliczenie zajęłoby
najszybszemu klasycznemu komputerowi ponad 300 bilionów lat.
Dużemu komputerowi kwantowemu pracującemu
z algorytmem Shora to samo obliczenie mogłoby zająć sekundy.
Złożone problemy tego typu istnieją we wszystkich branżach.
Potencjalne zastosowania quantum computing
są ogromne.
Komputery kwantowe już teraz stają się coraz większe
i coraz bardziej wydajne,
w miarę jak staramy się zmierzyć z coraz trudniejszymi problemami.
Od 2016 roku IBM udostępnia komputery kwantowe
publicznie przez stronę internetową z interfejsem graficznym, który
wygląda jak zapis nutowy.
oraz zestaw narzędzi deweloperskich Qiskit,
który pozwala użytkownikom programować komputery kwantowe.
Naukowcy wewnątrz i na zewnątrz świata korporacyjnego
przeprowadzają eksperymenty
przez podobne portale. Eksplorują podejścia do chemii
i problemów machine learningu, próbując ustalić,
jakie pytania będą mogli zadawać
i jak będą je formułować,
gdy technologia będzie bardziej zaawansowana. Teraz jest właściwy
moment, żeby liderzy biznesowi przygotowali się
na quantum. Warunki do eksperymentowania
i rozwijania tej fundamentalnie nowej technologii są już spełnione.
Organizacje, które chcą być na czele
tej przełomowej zmiany,
zdobędą przewagę konkurencyjną. To szkolenie
przygotuje cię do rozpoczęcia twojej kwantowej podróży!